for an estimated 115 million Americans
expected to travel in the coming days
Transportation secretary Pete Budaj is
already blaming storms for anticipated
holiday travel chaos now we talked we
may see some bad weather impacting
travel around Christmas and New Year's
FAA is working closely with Airlines to
plan for that possibility uh now so far
this year on the cancellation front
we're at 1.2% uh you know below two is
what I would consider healthy closer to
one if we can keep it that way that's
encouraging that does invite us to pay
more attention to the issue of delays
and to press the the airlines on how
they're behaving paying attention to
ever again i' like I'd like to tell
everybody Christmas is always December
25th uh July 4th is always July 4th we
seem surprised at times judge when these
these moments arve some in the country
do some in the government do what's your
reaction one in the government what what
is your reaction to the transportation
secretary my reaction is a negative one
I mean it started with Palestine and and
then and it's just went on from there uh
look I mean he knows and he knows there
were problems last year but do you
remember Thanksgiving he wanted to blame
the extremist Republicans for whatever
delays were going to happen at
Thanksgiving in case we shut the
government down which didn't happen but
look here's the thing I want to talk
about this thing this this uh uh here's
the thing so these people get less than
24-hour notice everybody the people have
taken off from work if you work your
kids are off from school uh the dog is
it they you know is it save money they
save the money this is a Christmas
present they got a banana boat and then
they say we're going to Boston you're
going to Boston so what they should have
done was they should have given them
their money back they said we'll let you
go on this cruise and then the people
were on the cruise since like 40% didn't
go they didn't even give them a better C
cabin they didn't give them an extra you
know thing here or there it was very sad
this seems like the cruise ship matter
seems like something that Transportation
secretary BL should be focused on cuz
those people need some some remedy I
think he's focused on the banana boat
instead Harold I didn't know you could
reserve a banana boat so I'm going to be
making Johnny make my
reservation I like control and when you
put yourself on a cruise ship you
totally lose control you're at the mercy
of the captain I want to be the captain
that's why I'm flying out the day after
Christmas and I'm going down south and I
just want to make everybody in the
audience aware it's much cheaper to to
travel in January don't travel if you're
listening don't travel in between
Christmas and New Year's travel in
January I'm not saying that selfishly so
it keeps the airport calmer I'm just
saying it's going to save you a lot of
money and according that's from a man
leaving December
26th true and I just read an article in
the post that said this Christmas season
there's going to be no white Christmas
not racial Harold there's going to be no
snow so I don't know how mayor Pete's so
ahead of the curve on the weather the
weather's going to be great well it
wasn't for the cruise DP you have
thoughts on this travel how well just
that I think that this does not um
alleviate any of my concerns about going
on a cruise uh but I do think this
company in particular doesn't sound like
a good one necessarily uh last year it
doesn't have to be the weather my
friends were going to ski over in Europe
they're at JFK airport they're ready to
go there's a fire somewhere at JFK
airport they're told we can get you a
flight in 4 days so what did they do
they pick up the kid they packed up the
kids got their luggage back from the
airline and they went home and they had
a nice Christmas at home a that's a
happy ending for really rich people who
get
the Swiss ski CH we'll have to wait oh
my goodness what are your thoughts about
this you I'm going to you know I'm going
to take an artificial stance are you
sure mayor Pete isn't working on the for
the ceasefire because he's better at
hindering Transportation than any mob of
foaming Pro protesters it's like this
guy every holiday travel season is the
very first one ever I didn't see this
coming he acts like it's co like oh wow
this just surprised us he has one job
and he acts like it's beneath his pay
grade he's unlearning not learning on
the job I have you know I but take some
blame off him the travel season travel
season is always chaos because
everybody's doing it once and and among
a season of the worst weather I think we
need to treat it like alternate parking
or like the Olympics you know if your
social security number ends in an odd
number then you celebrate Christmas one
year or stay home and then the other
part of the country does it and you you
flip it flop because yeah or can we like
or like one one group celebrates
Christmas in the summertime that's one
hell of an artificial stance it really
is no I'm actually real is that a real
stance or an artificial I now believe it
some people keep their lights up till
July that's true that's true Southwest
Airlines had a bad time bad Christmas
with Travelers they said they fixed
their systems we'll see and if they do
we to congratulate them and then may
just find them 140 million dollar who do
you think is going to have to pay for
that obviously the customer yeah in your
face Harold yeah yeah get on ban want
people that be able to get where they
want to go and I certain don't want my
flight diverted from down south to some
place really you don't want to go hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else